bien souvent dans les débats on s'énerve
et malheureusement quand on s'énerve
après c'est très difficile de continuer
à voir un bon débat du coup notamment
dans le livre à turbines principales
conventions les auteurs conseillent de
cherchait avant tout à arrêter le débat
si possible sur une autre pas trop
mauvaises ou par exemple une façon
possible de terminer le débat se dire à
l'autre que je suis désolé je suis un
peu trop frustré j'arrive pas à me
concentrer je n'arrive pas à bien poser
les choses est ce que ça te dérange dès
qu'on parle d'autre chose
et bien souvent c'est quand même
difficile de ne pas continuer à être
intérieurement énervé de ne pas se
calmer alors c'est souvent un parent
train de se calmer pour pouvoir mieux
poser notre réflexion
du coup je vous propose ici quelques
conseils pour mieux réussir à se calmer
et réussir à bien réfléchir au clair à
différentes idées le premier conseil que
je donnerais c'est de faire une activité
représente donc par exemple si vous
habitez en suisse la petite randonnée en
montagne
rien de plus à présent ces flux montagne
pour ça alors bien sûr si vous êtes à
paris je comprends que ça soit un peu
plus difficile de trouver un endroit au
cas où se relaxer un petit peu et
prendre le temps de respirer a mais
l'argent possible de faire d'autres
activités notamment par exemple faire la
vaisselle ou faire des tâches ménagères
qui libère un peu plus esprits ou alors
faire des activités sportives pour voir
s'est défoulé un petit peu sûrs dans un
contexte assez précis en particulier si
c'est une tâche sportive où il ya besoin
de la concentration
c'est encore mieux puisque le l'estrie
va se concentrer sur l'activité sportive
une mauvaise idée par contre ça serait
de se défouler sur autre chose tellement
a cassé quelque chose parce que souvent
on va exprimer notre colère pour
l'individu le débat qui vient d'avoir
lieu et en fait on va continuer à penser
à ce débat et ça va peut-être même
aggraver notre mécontentement et notre
colère et pour ça je vous renvoie
vraiment se faire cette excellente vidéo
ne tombe non
deux victoires ce qui est vraiment
absolument géniale et très en général je
recommande tout la série minefield de
vie sos qui est maintenant disponible
sur youtube allez voir ça c'est vraiment
de la top qualité approche consiste à
chercher à mettre les choses en
perspective finalement est-ce que le
désaccord connu est si grave que ça
c'est juliette qui vous ont fait
notamment la remarque que les experts
font souvent dans des débats extrêmement
tendue sur des sujets finalement des
considérations qui sont extrêmement
mineure surtout si on compare leur
position globale avec la position
extérieure ou du grand public et plus
normalement en attendant ça vraiment
s'énerver sur des choses qui sont pas
forcément les points les plus du plus
important
une bonne façon de chercher à se câliner
cd se demande vraiment quelle est
l'importance du sujet sur lequel il y à
cette tension et finalement s'il n'y a
pas des objectifs plus importants et
plus grandiose a considéré sur lequel
faire des progrès peut-être que
réfléchir à ça va permettre de mieux se
calmer et de mieux se fixer des
objectifs qui sont vraiment ceux sur
lesquels on aimerait avoir des réponses
intéressantes
un quatrième conseil pour
consiste à regarder des contenus de
divertissement parce que cela retire sa
est de ne plus penser au truc qui nous
agacent alors peut-être que tous les
universités ne se valent pas justement
les clés qui sont un peu à base de
scandales ou de violences vont peut-être
continuer à nous énerver
du coup je recommanderais plutôt des
trucs comme ces trucs un peu à base
d'humour ou de poésie des trucs de
merveilles scientifiques par exemple je
trouve que c'est compte tenu que je
consomme vraiment pour me calmer et que
je trouve vraiment présent on va
commencer par les vidéos de fribourg
hommes parce que c'est juste trop beau
tout ce qui fait un cinquième conseil et
là on commence à avancer de réponse est
un peu plus bizarre mais je trouve que
ça marche vraiment consiste à chercher à
se forcer à sourire fait le grand saut
l'air comme ça mais essayer de sortir
des blagues trouver parler de trucs
marrants
c'est un petit peu violence un peu
bizarre mais ça peut aider à se calmer
et encore une fois ce sujet je
recommande une excellente vidéo de la
série minefield de vie sos 1/6 conseil
c'est de voir l'autre non pas comme un
ennemi ou un adversaire mais comme un
message et ils râlent essaie de vous
communiquer une façon de penser qui bien
souvent est représentatif de toute une
population donc d'une certaine manière
le votre interlocuteur est quelqu'un qui
parle le plus ou moins au nom de tout un
groupe et en ça c'est juste un message
et il ya une utile de s'énerver contre
lui en particulier il ya quelque chose
de plus profond et de plus général
derrière tout ça et c'est pour ça qu'il
faut étudier plutôt que votre notre
interlocuteur en particulier des fonds
c'est votre interlocuteur ne changera
pas grand chose
et bien sûr si les seuls au monde à
penser ce qu'il pense ce que ça vaut
vraiment le coup de s'intéresser à ce
cas particulier
enfin la septième et dernière raison qui
est la plus bizarre c'est quelque chose
qui a été proposée notamment par le fils
le psychologue paul blum qui consiste à
déshumaniser l'autre ça peut paraître
assez bizarre a dit comme ça mais en
fait je trouve ça assez efficace c'est
de se dire que l'autre est en fait c'est
un algorithme cerveau qui suit des
instructions et qui fait juste qu
uniquement suivre ses instructions
et avec toutes les données qu'il a eu il
réagit de telle et telle manière qu'il
en vienne est venu à débat de la manière
dont cela des battus dernièrement
et du coup c'est vraiment une certaine
hier contre ce processus et rigaud
rythmique que vous débattez et je trouve
que se dire ça ça à calme beaucoup le
débat en particulier en fait on a
tendance à être vraiment énervé quand on
pense qu'il ya une faute d'un individu
de mais vraiment il ya quelque chose en
plus concerne l'individu quelque chose
qui est de l'ordre de la punition morale
et c'est un réflexe que l'on a et on
voit très bien dans une vidéo de vis aux
sentiments mais justement combattre ce
réflexe qui est pas forcément utile
lorsqu'on cherche à venir débattre
bah ça paraît assez utile est une façon
de se faire c'est de déshumaniser
l'autre ça veut pas dire qu'on souhaite
pas combien on peut très bien souhaité
le biais d'un algorithme mais ça aide à
ne pas sentir ce sentiment de trahison
qu'on en consomme parfois quand il
s'agit d'un humain et pas quand il
s'agit d'un algorithme
voilà ça fait plein de petits conseils
pour
calme je suis curé d'avoir des retours
alors sous cette vidéo par exemple
mais devrait être plus sur twitter j'ai
plus de chance de lire sur twitter que
sur youtube où il ya un peu trop de
commentaires et est pas tous très
intéressants
pourquoi